well
[Music]
hello how am I I came out jaramillo with the
most outstanding headlines for today
Monday November 2 tomorrow is the
official election day and the campaigns
continue to obtain the support of
Nevadans last night downtown meeting
held an event with voters to  in favor of
his father in wit chau he affirms
that the second term will bring a
rapid economic recovery for the
country while he called for a job air in a
corrupt and a cash politician today
the mayor of los angeles eric garcetti
will be in las vegas'  showing her support
for Democratic presidential
candidate joe biden carter and plans to
join a food drive event
with the nevada organization expect
ect laws parks law she
will later attend an event to encourage
the valley's youngest community to
come out and vote
[Music]
the thunderbirds prepare to fly
in the skies of the valley today as they
return from a show performed last
weekend pu  you can see them fly
around 12 55 this afternoon over the
south point casino they will be heading
north at low altitudes through the center
of the valley and now we turn to
the weather forecast we will have
partly cloudy skies with a high
reaching 83 degrees today  the
temperatures will be nice and
hot until Friday but at the
weekend they will drop around 60 degrees
prepare your coats have a nice
day piece and salt and jaramillo and this was
your brief informative of yuste out in
Spanish
[Music]